when i look at your early life it's a
pretty amazing story when you were in
high school you were the star athlete of
that school you were not only an
exceptional football player right you
were also an extraordinary basketball
player and had received several letters
from colleges wanting you to play
basketball for them right yes sir
and then at that crucial point in your
life you ended up
going to jail
and never going to college and playing
ball it was what was like a coke wrap
right you were dealing some coke yeah
and and is when you look back on that
that time in your life and they sent you
to jail
it could have been a whole different
career like you might have become a
professional athlete you were that good
am i correct i think that if i would
have pushed myself out i could have been
but i wasn't pushing myself i was more
entertained with the with the money and
the fast life and the things that were
were there accessible without the work
ethic
you know the fast money and the
basketball and the football required
practice and attention and coaching and
i wasn't really into that at that point
once i received you know my high school
introduction i was into the money and
the girls and trying to be something
that i wasn't and as i look back at it
i'm thankful that it happened like that
because it shaped me and molded me into
something that i that i'm proud of today
because if i'd have been an athlete i
don't think i would have been as great
as i am right now because i look at a
lot of athletes and their their peak
potential was only a certain amount of
years they don't have the ability to
recreate themselves and to try different
things and diversify their portfolio but
me
being the rapper that i was and the
person that i am i've been able to do
many different things because i'm not
restricted to just one sport or one
particular lane right in a way if you
would become a ball player maybe you
know you would had a couple of good
years who knows or maybe would fizzled
in college and all of that stuff but i
just i i wonder what it would have been
like for you to have gone to college and
maybe the fast life has to do with at 12
years old
you you join a gang
and i think when you're exposed to that
kind of lifestyle it almost becomes
inevitable that you're going to take a
different path right yeah but in the
beginning it's like the gang is not as
violent as they became it was the gang
was just the gang of the homies like my
friends we just were a gang that
was young and innocent and not knowing
and then as time went on 13 14 15
the neighborhood received drugs and guns
that were placed there for some apparent
reason right and then they got into the
wrong hands and then once they got into
the wrong hands things began to happen
and as you get older you experience
different things and you're challenged
with
being
you know someone who's scary or someone
who's down somebody who's scary ain't
gonna do no crimes and they're gonna try
to get involved but somebody who's down
won't really be trying to impress a lot
of people and doing things that are
stupid because he's young and i was in
the middle of you know both sometimes i
was scary sometimes i was down but i
appreciate the facts that i had the
opportunity to learn how to be who i am
now like at 12 they say you know you
were in the crips but were you
officially like in or was it just you
hanging out with your friends was there
ever there's no induction ceremony like
uh the mafia or something like that
right i was just hanging out infatuated
looking at the older guys and seeing
what they was doing and wanting to be a
part of it and they welcoming you in
because you young and then as you get
older it's like okay well you really
want to be in the game you got to do
something now now you got to prove
yourself and it's not a game no more
it's not a joke no more it's not just
hey we we hanging out no we need to do
something now and now it becomes are you
going to be that scary guy you're gonna
be that down guy and if you're a part of
a gang you really don't want to be that
scary guy were you ever afraid
when when people said to you finally
okay now it's either put up or shut up
and be cut and become a man quote
unquote according to the gang
did you ever experience fear or were you
fearless no i was always scared scared
i'm scared like that's why i believe i
survived because
you you have to either have fear or
respect and i didn't understand respect
so i feared everything so i was
basically moving and grooving trying to
figure out what to do and what not to do
a lot of times i got shot at a lot of
times i had a gun in my possession and
could have shot back but i was too
scared to shoot back because i was so
concerned with my life and see the fight
or flight and most of the time when
you're out there is flight how old were
you the first time someone handed you a
gun or you you had a gun in your
possession
how old were you that yeah you were
walking around with a gun 15 15 16. did
you even know how to fire the thing did
you did you
there's they don't send you to the right
yeah right there's no it's just only job
training basically on the job training
yeah you know you get it and if
something goes down you got to be ready
to go right then as far as your aim is
not going to be right and you know what
to do and how to how to handle the the
reaction and the rebuttal from the gun
all of that you just not used to it but
you try to act professional when the
time is caught upon because remember the
guys are looking at you they are and
everything's about the guys it's not
about you it's about you trying to
impress them as opposed to when you
become a real man if you're a part of a
gang you learn how to separate from the
gang you become an og and you start to
educate you start to teach the little
homies on how to do better and not to do
what you did and that's the point in the
part of my life that i'm at now to where
i become an og
and i teach and i you know give them
different routes and different avenues
to travel down football right rapping
entertainment you know things other than
what we had you once said that um you
know getting shot is not like in the
movies because in the movies the music
comes on and it tells you someone's
about to be shot
in real life you might be walking down
the street and suddenly a bullet hits
you right and you might not even know it
right
i mean what is that like to be shot
i mean i've never been shot but i've
been next to people who've been shot
i've been shot at and i've actually
been on the other end of that
so
with that being said it's a scary moment
because it can just happen like me and
you sitting here talking and robin is
over there talking and she brings us
something to drink and all of a sudden
somebody's
and then we have to react now you may
have a gun on you she may have a gun on
her but that doesn't mean that you're
going to shoot back no because you don't
even know what you're shooting at
exactly your life has to become
incredibly paranoid at that point you're
probably sitting at home i don't know if
your mother's there or something you're
like oh god i don't want to get her in
trouble i mean your whole life is you're
looking out both sides of the you know
you're looking all around all the time
wondering if you're safe it got to a
point to when my mother kicked me out
because she felt like
i was bringing too much drama to her
house with people wanting me and you
know the people i hung around and it
just didn't it didn't mix so she was
like you got to get out how old were you
when she kicked you out
i just turned 17. jesus and what do you
do i mean it's not like you got
somewhere to go where did you go
actually i um it was a lady that lived
on the spot because the spot where we
lived at was like a dope spot
and she was using crack and i had the
crack sack so she allowed me to stay
with her for a few pieces of crack
you know to live with her and then i
moved into my car had an automobile and
then one night
probably six months after my mama kicked
me out
my car was parked in the wrong side of
the street with all my clothes and all
my dope and it and it got towed away
so you were literally without
homelessness no dope no nothing just
from scratch like did your mother ever
try to say to you snoop what are you
doing i mean uh you know this this your
life's going to hell in a hand basket
i'm forced to kick you out did you feel
any kind of guilt or remorse about the
relationship with your mother no my
mother was a great mama you know i love
her to death because she she did what a
man was supposed to do there wasn't no
man in the house so as i look back i
respect her for it i didn't at the time
because i was like she's so mean she's
so hard on me why why and that made me
rebel but i understand now that she was
trying to prevent me from the things
that i went through and that's tough
love and sometimes these parents
nowadays need to use that tough love
because it's too much of that kid's
getting away with everything take a time
out i ain't had no time out
you